ciao a tutti mi chiamo guglielmo e in
questo video avrei potuto benissimo di
segnarvi la mia vita ma primi trent'anni
volevo fare qualcosa di nuovo e quindi
mi sono detto perché disegnarla come
posso benissimo mostrarla il 26 novembre
1987 sono nato qui all'ospedale di villa
san pietro e per l'occasione ho portato
[Musica]
la piccola quel cavallo rosso non
ricorda la rete guarda che primi piani
intensi un anno di guglielmo un anno è
stato ma io me lo ricordo che l'ho fatto
io con le mie mani netwo oltre a
mangiare le cose tue poi rubati dalle di
tuo fratello non è molto cambiato negli
anni questa cosa
sarà che la seco ndo cugino cugino si è
detto che è palla secco un mese dopo
questa foto a casa di nonna a casa
libera ma casino
mi sa che a questo punto mi tocca andare
in chianti e farvi vedere quella parte
della mia infanzia che nessuno conosce
questa è stata praticamente la casa
nella quale io ho passato la mia
infanzia è la cosa che mi fa più strano
è che non è cambiata molto nel corso del
tempo e ogni volta che ci vengono i
ricordi a niente non notte mi fa magna
sempre non li voglio ci si muovono anche
nei cream non può che grazie sì sì ma io
sto a posto
più tardi ho capito no sino a una grazie
sono costretto a mangiare in questo
momento mangiare quindi con bus treno
perché mi ricordo un parte dell'infanzia
o cancellato se non è stata del tutto
allegra questo è il posto dove andavo
alle elementari quando vivo a catania ho
bei ricordi legati a questo posto in
particolare legati a alla mia prima e
unica fidanzatina poi giù tu lo sai che
sei stata la mia unica fidanzata nella
vita
pure io pure io mi ricordo questa era la
mia merenda ragazzi
ogni pomeriggio andavamo in piscina
perché mia mamma era fissata io l'audi
avola oddio ecco la mamma mia barca la
devozione fissare le maioliche del
fondale per due ore di seguito ti porta
la pazienti porta veramente attira poi
il van gogh che in te quando non stavo
davvero o no io venivo qua questa è la
casa dove ha abitato fino ai 10 anni per
tutta la mia infanzia e poi cerca dei
miei nonni casa dei nonni era sempre
chiusa durante l'inverno perché non
c'erano quindi lo stato sempre in questa
e poi quando arriva l'estate gara il
momento più bello della mia vita si
apriva questa qui e venivano tutti
cugini e quant'altro
ed era sempre una cosa bellissima è una
cosa che lo testimonia ancora è che
facevamo delle foto di gruppo con tutti
quanti i miei cugini in one con t'altro
quindi abbiamo questa evoluzione da
quando erano piccolissimi e quando poi
invece siamo cresciuti purtroppo per
questo video avrei voluto che ci fosse
qui una persona che purtroppo non c'è
più mi sarebbe tanto piaciuto farvi
vedere questa questo caso comunque
raccontarvelo insieme a lui non
purtroppo non c'è più è però ho avuto la
fortuna di averlo
[Musica]
già possono se la passa male quando ero
più piccolo per tutte
pensavo che non ci fosse per me e non so
se per me è capitato di dire cacchio c'è
qualcuno che mi capisce c'è qualcuno che
veramente il sacco mista ci tiene la mia
forza era qui mi ha sempre incentivato a
sviluppare la creatività
l'unica cosa mi permetteva di uscire
veramente dal dal mio mondo entra in
mondi meravigliosi e perfetti vi voglio
far vedere una cosa stupenda ancora dato
che ben di guardatene tutti i fatti dal
mio nonno che ci faceva questo il tempo
trascorso in sicilia non è stato facile
continua a dirlo grazie al cielo quando
avevo dieci anni i mesi sono separati e
quindi in un'estate da qua siamo finiti
a roma per l'esattezza
qui siamo venuti a vivere temi i nonni
appena siamo arrivati a roma
se ti ricordi la cosa va beh noi andiamo
a roma per le vacanze spariti per
davvero e mio fratello 12 soggetti
rievocare i vecchi tempi giocando
all'autoscontro
ma quella è la più forte
il sole
da
io e mio fratello stiamo recuperando del
tempo perso fatto certo
ecco
se non dovessi valeva non è vero
non so se ce ne valevano ma insieme a
tele falsi in quell'acqua dietro alla
mia ex scuola media e credo di aver
odiato ogni istante passato qua dentro
qui è dove sono stato bulli dato da
altri ragazzini idioti mi davano del
[ __ ]
l'unica cosa salverà di questo posto è
il teatro bello questo parco sai noi ci
veniamo qui per per giocare in realtà
adesso ci andiamo a portare il cane
adesso ci vado dopo le medie che sono
stato un periodo orribile sono andato al
liceo è questo qui è il liceo giulio
cesare dove ho passato cinque anni della
mia vita e vi presento beckham la mia
compagna di banco storica la nostra
classe noi ne abbiamo avute varie un'era
la sopresa atto con cui governo bomba
rima primo di cui siamo venuti qua
perché c'è stato un periodo dove
venivamo sempre a mangiare a questo
cinese dopo la scuola
sinteticamente tutti gli anni del misero
si sperava malamente questa cinese a
diventarlo in cina già però non
conosciamo nessuno e la nostra vecchia
proprietaria non sappiamo dove sia fini
ma cos'è questa bellissima io la tua
amica lesbica a questa addio in cui
meglio per arrivare
perché atteso dalle ultime tre alla fine
o diosanto in cui tra l'altro ho trovato
niente di meglio da fare alla mia festa
che si vada rivisto questa dai pantaloni
anche noi non eravamo messi benissimo
che non ci credo quando a rifugiarmi mio
cervello averara comprare
ecco questa la via che ricordo di più in
assoluto per il nostro palazzo
questo è il nostro palazzo ricordo che
ho iniziato il mio canale su youtube qua
enrico era l'unico che mi dava una mano
a girare la roba era l'unico che ha un
minimo mica casse del ricordo che ero
sottoposto a sofferenze legato a questo
posto cielo degli insegnamenti più
grandi che abbia imparato nella vita che
ognuno di noi o no con shirley avevo la
libertà di dire quello che volevo a una
libertà di di seguire quello che volevo
avevo la libertà di essere chi volevo
che poi ci siano state tutte le
opportunità che ha portato c'è stato il
cinema la radio
ci sono state una radio ecc è stato
milano motivo principale per cui sono
venuto a milano è stato questo che è
stato ora dirige in questo che vedete
qui è il portone della mia prima casa
dove abitato da solo ogni week end
appena potevo tornavo a roma anche
perché c'era il mio cuore a roma e
quindi ne ho assolutamente tornare da
quella che era la mia dolce metà
forse anche per questo un po all'odiata
milano in quegli anni questa è la casa è
una cotta che dove sono venuto spesso
quando ero disperato e non sapevo cosa
fare
e lei la botta se ti dovessi chiedere
qual è un mio difetto è la risposta era
nessuno quando durante la giornata avevo
voglia di evadere venivo qua parco
sempione il più grande problema
sicuramente in quel periodo erano i miei
fantasmi lancio della mia sessualità i
fantasmi del passato dei miei genitori
il loro divorzio e continuavano
inseguirmi c'era il fantasma del bambino
che non voleva crescere e so di non aver
mai avuto questa infanzia avevo voglia
di riprendermi voglia di viverla prima o
poi problemi alcuni treni si perdono e
quando li perdi non li puoi più prendere
tornare qua con gli occhi di di un
adulto è sicuramente una conquista
perché fanno secondo e prendere un
pochino l'esperienza che ci capitano e
trasformarle gli insegnamenti o in alibi
la mia grande svolta è stata da tornare
a roma ma soprattutto trovare casa mia
[Musica]
se c'è una lezione che ho imparato dalla
vita l'aveva mai insegnato è stata
quella di continuare a camminare sempre
fare delle scelte trovarsi davanti a
debiti e capire dove dove andare ha
fatto capire effettivamente chi sono
oggi è un po una conquista
credo che tutti noi siamo un pochino una
nostra conquista
io vi auguro veramente di trovare un
posto che che possa per voi essere casa
e non è per forza essere un posto
materiale per anzi li auguro che sia un
posto invisibile che magari avete dentro
gli auguro di guardarvi ogni mattina
allo specchio con gli stessi occhi che
quali riguardano le persone che vi
vogliono bene e adesso non so più come
finire questo video
[Musica]